i'm headed to the lost city of chan chan
once the beating heart of the mighty
chimu empire
is that a pyramid i think that's a
pyramid
a pyramid and changing
can i find answers inside the city walls
as to why the children had to die
[Music]
built over a thousand years ago
amazingly much of the city has survived
[Music]
and i've been told to expect something
spectacular
[Music]
look at these walls
this stretch as far as the eye can see
[Music]
i've got my drone up taking a closer
look right now
[Music]
looks like a labyrinth of walls
i'm using photogrammetry data with
graphic modeling to rebuild the city
and these extraordinary walls
here they are restored to their full
glory
a truly awe-inspiring sight rising out
of the desert like something out of a
fable
at its dazzling peak in the 15th century
the city was a bustling home to 60 000
people
about the size of london at the time
and covering 14 square miles
this is one of the greatest cities of
human history
so why did it collapse
so suddenly
[Music]
i'm here to meet
peruvian archaeologist arturo pereiras
he's been working here
for years
ironically his last name means wall
[Music]
antero
look at all these carvings here it's
it looks like uh
like digital fish
the chimu covered the city with carvings
of the ocean
wow
look at these
they're everywhere
but among all these artworks
is one arturo really thinks i need to
see
an entire wall in the central palace is
devoted to a giant mural over 170 feet
long
oh
wow
[Music]
look at this
[Music]
what is this
fish yes primer plant and each one of
these
is actually a wave moving down towards
the coastline
are these currents
all these fish they're going in a
direction they're traveling from
south to north they're actually
following the course of
of a current the peruvian current
but a closer look reveals that the mural
also depicts a moment of great change
another current coming back in the other
direction
fish swimming in the opposite way
north
to south
incredible is this right did i get this
did i get this
it looks like the chimu are recording a
dramatic shift in the ocean currents
and when that happens something else
dramatic happens too
a violent shift in the climate
[Music]
with the chimu recording a huge natural
disaster on those walls
were they chiseling a premonition of
their own destruction
[Music]
i need to check the data
[Music]
to see if they were right
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a dry arid desert but a sudden
switch in the pacific ocean current can
trigger violent change
and devastating rain
but look at this
everything flips because the ocean
currents are tied to the weather
currents
everything's tied together
i know this kind of thing i live on the
pacific coast myself just in north
america
this climate shift is called an el nino
these days it happens about once every
five years
but once in a generation you get a
really big or long lasting event
that's called a super el nino
and the impact
can be catastrophic
wait a minute look at this the data
right here this rainfall dated every
year for the last decade
less than half an inch of rain and then
boom 2017 one big spike
four inches of rain in a single year
completely out of the blue
it happened as recently as 2017
destructive floods in peru caused by
torrential rains triggered
by a severe el nino
maybe there's clues in the experiences
in that el nino
that'll tell me what might have happened
to the chimu
i'm gonna go try to meet some people
in 2017 the city of trujillo just three
miles from chan chan and also sandwiched
between the sea and the mountains was
one of the worst hit
[Music]
i'm here to meet some people
i almost lost everything
one local family filmed the flood as it
tore through their home
never seen anything like this before
this much moving material water just
rushing down through the
through the streets this whole thing
would have been a river oh you can
actually you can actually see the storm
in the background
the more i talk to people in trujillo
the more i hear this word fico
it doesn't sound like spanish to me
huecos is quechua or is
it
quechua is an ancient language of peru
pre-dating the spanish
wow that's incredible this has happened
so many times for so long that there's
an ancient word it's something that's
embedded in the memory
[Music]
an avalanche
this term waco is used to describe
a combination of water mud stone debris
coming not from the ocean in the west
but from the east and the mountains
behind the city
[Music]
is it possible
that the same type of event happened to
the chimu
if it did then there must be some way of
finding
evidence that an el nino event happened
in their time
the answers
may be up in those mountains
[Music]
you